il entre dans l'histoire si Jean Ping
l'homme politique chinois le plus
puissant depuis Mao sort de ce congrès
renforcé et incontesté
sans précédent soutien-t-il
pour la première fois en 25 ans aucune
femme n'accède au bureau politique les
hautes sphères du pouvoir chinois
cet homme au sommet le comité permanent
dans la nouvelle garde rapprochée de si
Jean Ping la loyauté prime les quatre
nouveaux venus sont tous fidèles au
président autoritaires le Premier
ministre le vice-Premier ministre actuel
sont écartés
problème de santé ou message politique
l'ancien président Houdin Tao avait été
poussé lui aussi vers la sortie samedi
et fondamentalement le Parti communiste
chinois est un parti d'origine
soviétique
ça mène très souvent vers une
concentration totale du pouvoir dans les
mains d'un homme on l'a vu avec Mao on
l'a vu avec Staline
politique zéro covid contraignante
ralentissement de l'économie toute
chômage de 20% chez les jeunes tensions
avec les États-Unis et l'Europe les
défis sont pressants et nombreux pour la
Chine de seging et c'est Philippe
Leblanc Radio-Canada